noon tonight the rental truck shortage
continues to cause problems for las
vegas especially those who are trying to
move marco mana spoke to a man who went
to extreme lengths just to get the car
he needed i can't work with babies when
i gotta be out of my house terence
o'connor is moving from las vegas to
austin texas but one day before he was
supposed to get his u-haul he got a call
from the company
o'connor tells me he had everything
scheduled for weeks he changed the
pickup day a while ago but was told that
was fine but what i wasn't told was that
they might cancel me so why am i
responsible for what you didn't tell me
i tried getting answers from the u-haul
store o'connor spoke with but was told
to contact corporate those familiar with
the industry say the issue is a shortage
of vehicles at rental truck companies
the little the littler van u-hauls were
typically used a lot by people
that couldn't get a rental car because
of the pandemic tremaine johnson used to
own a moving company but now runs a junk
removal service he says the shortage is
bringing unexpected customers his way
and we don't do moving typically too
much but we did get a lot of calls to
come and move just a few you know small
things o'connor finally got a u-haul but
says he had to drive more than three
hours to get it in tonepaw i'm happy
that i
have some solution i don't think it's
right at any level that it's on me to
fulfill the commitments that they made
to me orco mana live local now
now u-haul got back to us late tonight
and admitted o'connor was contact a
little later in the process and the
company would have liked they also point
out equipment is in high demand so local
teams are working to connect customers
with different pickup locations or even
changing the moving days in order to
accommodate everybody